So if we're considering something
that looks very similar to our paper
prototype why would make one?
For this, it's important to go back
to the idea of circles of feedback.
Our paper prototype was a thing that we
could show to people who were near by
and who we knew.
The medium fidelity prototype will be
something we can show to subject matter
experts and users as well.
By expanding our net we can gather more
information on the apps experience from
each of these vital perspectives.
With an interactive prototype we
can ask users to complete tasks and
see how they go about doing it.
We can ask them to explore the app
looking for a certain functionality.
And most importantly we can
get out of their way and
see the raw reaction to the app.